I'm a little bit nervous about exposing
the secret and I also don't want to like
brick his heart we're here so I can tell
my dad a secret that I've been keeping
for like 16 years I'm nervous I don't
know what kind of secret she could have
since she's four I'm really not that
nervous I don't think he's gonna be that
mad sometimes it makes more sense not to
say something if it means you're not
gonna get in trouble I guess I'm excited
to learn about the secret I can't
imagine he'd have anything to hide from
me the dad Nicole what's the one thing
that we used to do together when I was a
child remember when you would ask me
like oh do you want to play tennis or
golf today
yes my answer 100% of the time would
have been tennis because I really really
don't like golf and I never liked
playing it and I just went because I
like wanted to have something to do with
you that wasn't me beating you at tennis
and I also think that watching golf is
really boring and I don't understand
like watch it about two months ago I got
those parking tickets and you gave me
the money and a normal person would have
mailed it in and then you called me one
day and were like you never paid the
tickets I had to pay the late fee and it
was about double what the ticket was and
I told you that it was just a city's
fault I was like I paid the tickets kept
the money and I spent it but what did
you do with the money 7-eleven $400 on
this floor pays huge got to do like a
weights been lifted off my shoulders now
that you know and I'm probably not gonna
watch off you ever again that's fine
just even how surprised are you it got
to a point where it became obvious that
she wasn't that interested in it not
that big of a deal
there was late fees you could have just
paid the ticket you would put the ticket
on my credit card
anyways I could have put it on the
credit card and kept the money that
probably would have been smarter why
would that be hard I don't know because
you can love it that doesn't break my
heart actually heartwarming because at
that young age at four years old you
would do something that you didn't
really like doing because you want to
spend time together I'm the greatest now
I feel like there's probably more things
that you should be doing it's busted
no that's about as bad as it gives I
thought you would be like oh really I
kind of expected you to feel cheated out
of a daughter who likes golf well we can
do that another okay
cool and how do you feel about you
exposed supposedly your were secret feel
about the same I still like spending
time with you though I mean you've just
got another parking ticket last month
did you pay it yeah I paid it mm-hm
there are other secrets I don't know I
should actually pay you when you pay the
ticket on time so if I pay the ticket on
time you give me double the money I'll
give you half of the late fees this
looks like it worked out better for me
that I told him the secret
[Music]
[Music]